on the mound ryan weathers enters
tonight game with a 2-2 record with a
2.06
e-r-a last time weather's pitched it was
tuesday night at wrigley field in
chicago so he gets a second straight
whack at these guys
that is strike three got him looking
got him o2 worked it full and it's a
breaking ball froze him right on the
inner half one down here in the first
inning for chris bryant
2-1 pitch
and a ground ball lots of spin on it out
towards cronenworth's got a hurry and he
gets it there just in time two down two
down nobody on here's anthony rizzo the
1-1 rizzo lines one left center field
that's a base hit
loving it on one hop is pro far and
getting it back in so against this tough
lefty he hangs in there left-handed
batters hitting just 174 against
weathers coming into this ball game two
down rizzo at first base and brings up
patrick wisdom rizzo will run now on
three and two the pitch to wisdom is
swung on in missed strength three it was
a slider had him reaching for it and a
scoreless first with a couple of k's for
ryan weathers on the mound is advert
well the 26 year old making his 11th
start slider to
four-seamer changeup and a curveball we
saw him in chicago has allowed three
runs or fewer in nine consecutive starts
tommy fam been getting on base a lot and
leading it off
here for the padres we'll line this one
to right center field and he's going to
get on base with that base hit his on
base percentage is 550 when he leads off
an inning well we are in the first guest
who's leading off lead runner on for
manny machado
on the ground right side and sogard
he's gonna be late
they were shifting on machado so we had
to go from the left side of the infield
to the right side and was not hit that
hard so by the time he got over there it
was too late and machado beats it out
our base is loaded nobody out for
fernando
tatisha know he's going to want to do
damage he's going to be looking to swing
here here comes
swing and a miss he struck him out
strike to ball slider it is
just perfectly executed really good work
there a young pitcher who could have
really gotten into panic mode there aces
loaded one down eric cosmere standing in
on the ground right side slowly hit
sogard will flip to first a ruddell
score van comes in from third the padres
get a run and the cubs will take that
exchange that's out number two osmer
picks up an rbi here's the pitch swag
and a miss strike three he got him on a
curveball
and he gets out of it with minimal
damage the padres get one
with a runner at first nobody out
hitting it just 190 so far this year
does have six home runs
and a grounder down to third machado to
second for one honda first for two
around the horn they go on the 543 dp
i love it when they play catch on the
infield that's pretty smooth smooth as
silk
fan single to center field in the first
and a buck has been charged here to
alzheimer's
third base for carratini looked like he
started and then stopped can't do that
it's against the rules he's peering in
starts right there just that little bit
he raised up a little bit and stopped
runner goes at first the pitches strike
throw down to second and safe
another stolen base for tommy pham who's
been running a lot lately so the padres
all year two in scoring position now for
manny chance to do some damage here in
the second inning
to left field wisdom
will make the catch tagging at third is
carratini he will score bad throw back
in
and the padres have a two-nothing lead
sac fly for machado slider
last couple of slides it's down but not
out enough
shortly by fam at second and the two one
by alzali
swung on hit high in the air into right
field shallow and playable for bryant
he's got it to end the inning the padres
get another run two down pro far at
first and brian o'grady
fly ball center field struck well
mariznick
welcome back brian o'grady just
activated tonight it's a two run home
run and the padres lead at four nothing
it's a good fastball hitter right here
he didn't get to see enough of him in
the first second at bat he gets that
fast ball he's looking for guess who's
going to wear the swag chain brian
o'brady swinging the shelly oh and two
and now the cubs have a great scoring
chance bases loaded nobody out for jake
mariznick's dad here's jake mariznick a
single his first time that one taps
softly up along first
throw and it gets away one run is in
here comes another rizzo across and
they've scored twice
and it's now four to two it'll probably
be a hit and a throwing error by
weathers allowing the second run to
score one out second and third 4-2
here's a high fly ball left field that's
going to drive in a run
fam is going to make the catch tagging
and scoring is patrick wisdom and now
it's a 4-3 ball game well good job by
alcantara as he gets this breaking ball
up and out over the plate pulls it and
gets it elevated
now's lie
with a walk
he just has not had the good command the
last pitch that elzalei threw was 90
miles an hour if that was his fastball
it's not even close to his good fastball
well there was something that just was
not
totally right for him here this evening
certainly not with the way
he was commanding the baseball five
walks and he walks off with pj
maineville the blister on his right
middle finger for alsalon starting
pitcher for the cubs one ounce second
and third for san diego in a one-two
pitch fam grounds one to first rizzo's
coming home
safe
kiratina gets in
he is slow to get up hurt himself on the
slide padres have a 5-3 lead
rizzo so smooth with the glove the throw
is short-hopped at the plate oh he got
his
yeah his foot caught on that knee of
contreras his right foot you can see his
leg they continue to check on him in
some pain runners at the corners now
with one out for the padres and manny
machado
manny lines it to left wisdom moves over
to make the catch tagging is kim
he will score the padres take a 6-3 lead
sac fly for manny machado let's see if
he and half can crank up a little cubs
rally in the seventh
half drills that one to center well
struck pro far back near the wall and
it's gone
i think he would have had a play on that
to at least jump but he mistimed it and
then effectively bumped into the wall of
homer and hat gets a run back
and they are within two tommy pham with
a single a pair of walks and he drove in
a run with a fielder's choice bouncer
his last time up the 1-1 from abbott
going on grounded a third sharply gloved
by wisdom the throw to first gets him
and the inning is over the padres don't
score we go to the eighth inning abbott
just needs to put a try to put a zero on
the board and keep the cubs within two
swings here pops it up on the infield
rizzo is coming in contreras going out
rizzo makes the call and he can't make
the catch he was in foul territory kind
of hopped up at the last moment and the
ball ended up coming down and hitting
him in the chest two and two hit in the
air to right field pretty well struck
ryan going back towards the corner at
the wall looking up gonna go
manny machado with a home run his eighth
of the year and the padres lead is three
here in the eighth and the rizzo error
proves costly for the cubs talking about
giving a hitter new life get that man
the swag chain
line into right center field here comes
cronenworth
with run number eight of the night for
the padres who take an 8-4 lead
a drive to right down the line towards
the corner and it is a fair ball rattles
around in that corner
from first hosmer is going to be waved
around he will score it's a double and
an rbi for brian o'grady and it's a 9-4
padres lead on the ground right side
this could do it the second for one on
the first for two
double play ends the ball game and that
is a winner padres take it 9-4 over the
cubs